[Music]
hey what's going on YouTube now today's
video is going to be interesting because
there aren't going to be too many
giggles but I'm going to be talking
about something pretty serious now
topically speaking today I'm going to be
talking to you about something that
everybody has been asking but nobody has
really given you answers for today on a
serious note let's talk about how you
can become a youtuber not just any
youtuber not just someone who put some
branded videos but somebody who is very
successful at it and somebody who can
actually make a [ __ ] living out of
this now if you're just here to be
entertained it is something that you
don't really give two [ __ ] about you
can click away and you know go back to
your weird [ __ ] porn is that [ __ ]
elephant porn you're looking at
something i watch that stuff too but
let's talk about who this video is for
it is for anybody and everybody who has
looked at youtubers such as me or people
who were even bigger than the out there
and said I want what you have I want to
do what you do if you have sat around
working a nine-to-five and a job that
you [ __ ] in hate or you just want to
create art or express yourself for a
living this video is going to be for you
and listen I'm only saying this because
the person that I'm describing before
that used to be me I remember a time
when I was in college and straight up I
did not want to be there I'm a Korean
American I Korean parent saying crazy
[ __ ] like
epu doesn't go to college it just
straight up I was just doing this to
make my parents happy and I was [ __ ]
miserable I remember every day when I
was in class I had a notebook open right
and in this notebook I would constantly
be writing and what people will look
over when I'm writing it wasn't class
notes
it was stand-up comedy pitch that I was
working on because being a stand-up
comedian or a comedian was always on my
mind that's the only thing I wanted to
focus on and you know from an outside
perspective when people look at that
notebook people are thinking hey he's
just daydreaming about [ __ ] that he
can't had well they were [ __ ] wrong I
was endangering I was working on
something to be at a place where I
belong now before we start this I do
have to get this out the way there's
already a few of you [ __ ]
out there that are saying I can't
listen yes you [ __ ] can you think I'm
any more special than you are I'm not
listen just two weeks ago I just stopped
sucking dick for sandwiches I got to
stop saying that joke because people are
starting to believe it all right well
now that's out of the way let's get into
it some of you may or may not already
know this but all it's going to take is
one viral video now for me it would be
Alexander Wallis video where I kind of
did this rant and I went off on this
girl and I roasted the [ __ ] out that
[ __ ] and I tried like 50k subscribers
overnight and if you subscribe because
that you also know that immediately
after that video I continue to do more
and more and more and the reason why is
because when you do have that one viral
hit people are waiting and wondering
what your next move is and that my
friends is a great problem to have
because once you get that viral video
you now have a audience waiting for you
but it also begs the question how do I
get that one viral video because
honestly it sounds a lot easier said
than done but this my friends is
something that they don't tell you about
most people think that it's all about
love and to a certain extent it is but
also there are certain ways to increase
your chance of getting lucky a [ __ ] ton
of youtubers have used this technique
though they don't know that this is what
it's called or they don't know that they
actually used it they have been doing
something called rapid content testing
now if you're still with me this is
important to listen up going viral is
all about finding a repeatable video
format that [ __ ] works now this
reputable format has to align with your
channel topic your personality and your
audience and what it does trust me
you're off making babies when you find
the right video format you can plug
almost any video idea into it it's a
mole as long as you have the right mole
to pour your videos into you will have a
higher chance of going viral
before we go even further into this let
me talk about something very important
I mentioned just a moment ago the
personality aspect of YouTube YouTube is
all about personality and it's all about
you for the most part people watched
YouTube content creators because the
connection that they have with them
right that's like you could have
something like the ice bucket challenge
which yeah it has been done a million
times over but no matter how many people
do it it always goes viral because
people can put their own unique twist to
it and that's where that personality
part comes in most people think viral
videos happen only with original ideas
and that's actually wrong and the reason
why is because people like seeing that
content creators do the things that are
vital because they feel a connection to
them they don't want to see it from
somebody else they want to see it from
you and this looks back to why it's so
critical for you to find that content
format now how do you find that format
you ask once again we're talking about
rapid content testing you need to
rapidly test a lot of different types of
formats until you find one that
absolutely crushes it your content
format is primarily going to depend on
your personality your unique take on
things and how you view the world
now follow along with me because let's
look at this in the context of my
channel before the Alexander Walz video
my content was very different now the
videos that I rapid content tested with
aren't there anymore but I used to do
long format stand-up comedy on my
channel this one is really working
because long-form aesthetic comedy
wasn't something that people wanted to
see at the time they wanted something a
little bit more quick and more
gratuitous especially with the jokes and
on top of that too if you look at some
of the previous videos before Alexander
Wallace
they were a lot more calm they were a
bit more subdued because I was doing
stuff that I thought that people would
want to see rather than creating
something that was about my personality
of who I was so when I threw that [ __ ]
out the window and I kind of just did
what was me which was natural to me
which was talking [ __ ] my channel blew
up things started going at it and when I
found that format which did take a
couple of months I stuck with it I
worked on it and now I'm here the point
that I'm trying to make right now is
that anybody can do this you just need
to find that repeatable content format a
mistake that a lot of people make when
they start off their own YouTube is that
they tried one idea and when it fails
they quit altogether or even worse when
a Content idea fails they keep doing the
same one over and over
and over and that's about the worst
thing that you could do and this is why
testing new ideas is so critical the
great thing about being a content
creator is that you could literally
create content out of anything I mean in
my case I can calm me
other people do make up [ __ ] other
people do sports stuff people do fitness
there are people out there who could
probably pick their [ __ ] nose and get
millions of views there's a girl who
takes a piece of bread especially into
her face there will always be a group of
people that want to watch your stuff
it's just about finding the right way to
deliver your content the biggest thing
that I want you to take away from this
video is the fact that it is not
impossible once again how many times
have I heard you know I can't do it
because I'm not you it's not something
that's tangible shut the [ __ ] up yes you
can after watching this video to be
honest with you you really don't have
any more excuses so the only person
stopping you is you remember keep going
and test out these content ideas that
eventually will have a synergistic
relationship with you and the content
that you want to create a safe energetic
fun college [ __ ] it kind of
pisses me off how on this space there's
a lot of like influencers or youtubers
that say [ __ ] like you know if you want
to do it just go ahead and do it
individual you'll get there bah bah but
Cernik said yeah that's true but they
don't actually ever tell you how to do
it right there has never been something
out there that has given you a
step-by-step plan for starting your
channel I've mentioned before when I was
going on a small hiatus from putting out
these videos that I was working on
something very special and this is
actually it but before I get into that
I'm pretty sure a lot of you are
wondering like why I'm doing this in the
first place why am i teaching people how
to become a youtuber the whole point of
what I'm going to show you and the whole
point of this video is just to tell you
right now that becoming a social-media
influencer or being on this space can
change your life listen I don't know the
reasons why you even want to become a
social-media influencer but it could
even be something as simple as you want
financial freedom to do whatever the
[ __ ] you want or maybe you work a
[ __ ] nine-to-five job that you hate
but you have somebody breathing down
your neck telling you what to do that
cycles your creativity every
second of the day or my case you get
tired of doing stuff just because people
tell you that it's the right thing to do
and you look at yourself and you say hey
what I want to do is connect with people
and make people live well that's what
this platform did for me so let me tell
you what this project is and what I have
been working on with Jesse from simple
pickup if you don't know who Jesse is
jesse is the co-founder of a channel
called simple pickup
it has about like 2.7 million followers
or so and they actually turn that
platform into a multi-million dollar
business over the past five years now
jesse has actually put together a
four-part program that I'm actually a
part of so for the next few days Jesse
and that kind of work this thing out we
are going to give you free access to
this program if you go to the
description box below and click that
link and sign up if you reach this part
of the video you're obviously interested
in this is something that you actually
want to do in video 1 you're going to
learn a special process for finding your
perfect channel idea that in video 2
you're going to learn how to come up
with great content ideas using something
called a remix strategy in video 3
you're going to learn how to attract
your initial audience and even turn that
into an actual business Wow and it isn't
for you you don't have to click on it
but if you made it this far through the
video I guarantee you you will and this
is not going to be something that you'll
regret so if you fought with me and this
is what you want click that link and
start watching the first video and I'll
see you guys over on the next page just
for the people who are interested in
this [ __ ] and who knows maybe the next
time that you are on this channel
watching this video you'll be watching
not only as a viewer but also as a peer
on the social media platform and I'm
telling you right now that if that
happens it would probably be the
happiest happiest moment of your life
and also mine like I always say fam life
is always what you're making but it's up
to you to take what you deserve let's go
for broke
[Music]
[Music]